all right let's rip through some of the
other news happening in the national
football league phillip rivers new
quarterback of the indianapolis colts
kick it used to saying that at least the
helmet will still be white frank wright
the coach of the colts says that rivers
knows 80 to 85 percent of the playbook
this goes back to the connection to nick
ciriani who was the offensive
coordinator with the chargers he's now
the offensive coordinator with the
uh colts he may have been quarterback's
coach or something like that maybe not
offensive coordinator but still the
connection is there so the offensive
knowledge is there that's going to make
the transition easier chris especially
without an off season program
definitely i mean i think that's the the
appeal that philip rivers you know had
to the indianapolis colts as there was
going to be no learning curve we could
go in and just hit the ground running
and i mean
watch out for the colts mike i mean the
culture one of those teams we just got
to put there right now
especially with phillip rivers at
quarterback
and say they're to me they're one of
those teams on the out you know just on
that outside where we should say watch
out for them to be a super bowl
contender they're going for it right now
they're telling you they're going for it
they think they can go and be a super
bowl contender this year phillip rivers
the deforest buckner trade okay you know
their offensive line their defensive
front is really good the linebackers
just in houston they got a lot of good
guys uh on their front four and they can
send waves at you they gotta get their
secondary right and they're making
strides to do that god xavier rhodes
added somebody else too but you know i
get it and i think that colts are a team
i would say you know one of those teams
where every year we see a team that
doesn't make the playoffs that surges up
the next year and we go whoa where did
they come from the colts will be one of
those teams i think we should have on
our radar
frank reich also added that jacoby
brissette wasn't happy about being
pushed aside for philip rivers but
brisette is quote a good teammate and
quote taysom hill has been a very good
teammate and a very effective weapon for
the new orleans saints sean payton
appearing on espn on tuesday said first
and foremost we still view taysom hill
as a quarterback we spent a lot of time
this offseason discussing our vision for
him this season at quarterback i think
taysom sees himself as being a starting
quarterback in this league and we do
too chris unless there was any doubt the
saints view taysom hill as their guy and
by all appearances he will be the
successor to drew brees
yeah well i mean this is no surprise to
you and i we've been hearing the rumors
about taysom hill and the love love
affair that the saints have with him and
sean payton especially hey there's big
time talent he has superstar type
potential he really does so you know i
think that's what he sees about him he
realizes he can orchestrate a different
offense that he's never had before and
also in that interview mike you know the
freudian slip of sean
saying this will be drew brees last year
he signed up for one more year or last
year however he said it i mean that just
tells you too so yes i think sean
payton's very excited about you know
what what taste of hill could be as a
quarterback
the unique situation with our team and
with our quarterback drew brees is he's
announced he's coming back for his final
season that is what sean payton said and
we were both on the same page on
this is the first time you you used to
butcher a word then you figured out and
now you've fallen off the horse again
and you're back yeah
just freudian i'm going to start saying
freudian for crying out loud well i'm
afraid of cardinals sorry have begun
contract discussions with new receiver
deandre hopkins he has three years left
on his current deal based salaries 12.5
million 13.5 and 13.9
what do you think that he's going to end
up getting per year
well you know no crap they're in
contract negotiations for them i mean
they better be i mean again we're seeing
two examples right now laramie tunzel
jalen ramsey i'd be worried if you make
this type of trade right and then you
don't you know have the guy locked up
and happy he has all the leverage so yes
get that deal done if you're the arizona
cardinals and i would think that it's
right up there challenging julio jones
or anything like that i think that
deandre hopkins is going to command
somewhere between 20 and 23 million
dollars a year because that he's the
next guy up he's in the conversation for
one of the best receivers in football
and that's the trend we always see
i agree with you and it is going to be a
significant number it's one of the
reasons why the texans traded him and if
they failed in any respect they should
have gotten that idea out there ahead of
time so people weren't so shocked when
they heard that deandre hopkins was
going to become a member of the arizona
cardinals and that the texans were
getting hardly anything in return for
him one more real quick chris godwin
buccaneers receiver on jameis winston by
the way godwin officially giving up
number 12 for number 14 so tom brady can
wear 12. what a shock tom brady's
wearing number 12. number 15 the magic
number though in godwin's mind as it
relates to jameis winston he recently
said that winston should have had half
of his total interceptions half of them
were other people's faults half of them
were winston's fault that's 15
interceptions for winston instead of 30.
but you know chris
every quarterback
whatever their number is whether it's
eight whether it's 30 whether it's two
whether it's five whether it's 40.
there's a certain percentage that
weren't their fault so i get it
they're not all his fault but they're
never all the quarterback's fault but
they still all go on the quarterback's
records that that's right i think chris
codman's kind of being nice too and and
good for him chris godwin
he is showing not only is he a hell of a
football player but he's a great
teammate and that really understands the
big picture first off very unselfish uh
to give away the number 12 good for him
for doing that he's been wearing 12
since he's a little kid so it has
importance to him but he understands
it's tom brady and then yeah i think
he's trying to be a good ex teammate to
jameis winston there but yeah i think 15
is being kind of kind i would say you
know okay maybe there's eight to ten
that you could say maybe isn't jameis
winston's fault but i'd also say there's
probably eight to ten that were also
should have been intercepted and were
dropped passes and things like that too
so it's hard to defend jameis winston
and the turnover problems he has
and here we are well into free agency
and there has been nothing about jameis
winston no sniffs dealers no no
no
yeah i don't think it's gonna happen all
right we gotta take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports